now the newly appointed head of the
world organization is calling for enough
vaccines for everyone
angosi oconjo iwala has warned against
vaccine
nationalism that would slow progress in
ending the kobit-19 pandemic
and could erode economic growth for all
countries rich
and poor countries such as
south africa and india are trying to
persuade the wto to eliminate patents to
help fight the global pandemic
it would enable them to produce generic
vaccines cheaply
the pharmaceutical manufacturers say
patents reward
inventions they cover the high costs of
research
without this compensation there'd be no
enhancements
no new drugs and vaccines
and for more on that issue i'm joined
now by elizabeth
masoute from the doctors without borders
access campaign here in berlin good to
have you with us
let's just first talk about the new head
of the wto because until
the end of last year uh okonjo iwala
chaired the global vaccine alliance gavi
which aims to increase access to
vaccines around the world
how hopeful are you that her appointment
now will help the cause of developing
nations
in this pandemic
yes obviously it's great to have someone
as experienced
as her now to have the wto in this times
of crisis in this times of a global
pandemic
and someone with the awareness of what
the needs are
the dire needs to get vaccines in the
global south
so yeah we are hopeful that this will
maybe also push
members who are actually the ones who
have to vote on the issues you've
mentioned
the waiver that has been proposed by
india and south africa which is
supported now by over 100 countries
but also blocked by some rich countries
namely also canada the u.s the european
union
so it will still be up to member states
to push push this waiver and to vote for
it so that it can actually go into
action
so that we see more vaccines for
everybody worldwide
so i mean you just mentioned i mean
india and south africa
put forward a quite interesting proposal
they want to produce generic
drugs and vaccine of course to fight
kobit 19 rather than wait
for the more costly and scarce original
drugs
what are those stomping blocks why are
nations not supporting it
we as doctors without borders have seen
now for 20 years
that yeah intellectual property rights
such as patents for example can be
barriers to
access so we've seen this in the past
and it is happening again now in the
pandemic
so as you said the waiver doesn't only
include
vaccines it also includes drugs and also
includes testing so diagnostics
but also personal protective equipment
or ventilators
so this would be something to to break
barriers all around to access and also
affordable access
and yeah in a time of scarcity and where
we have a few companies
who are struggling to supply the global
demand like we've never seen before so
it's natural
that not only a few countries can supply
this vast demand um as soon as possible
of course as you mentioned also
affordability um
developing a new drug is costly there's
a lot of
research and development pharma
companies
rightly so expect to be paid for their
services
so who's going to foot the bill if
everybody did agree to basically say all
right
let's make this vaccine which is the
most
much sought after right now let's make
it available for everyone now
well as we've seen last year massive
amounts of public money have been
invested
in the research and development of these
vaccines so
it's actually also the public that has
been footing this bill
and it is i would disagree when somebody
says patent is the or patents are the
only driver for innovation
it is also public investment and there's
also other incentives
that should go um yeah into this
consideration
and they're already the companies
already have
secured contracts as we've seen with the
european union with the u.s and so forth
so what we would have liked to see is
that if these
massive amounts of public money have
been invested there should have been
strings attached
to this money to say yes the public will
part on fund yeah push the funding but
there needs to be strings attached on
transparency so how expensive
is this drug actually or this vaccine
how much did the company invest in it
how much of that did the public pay for
it and
will there be strings attached for
affordable pricing
and also for technology transfer maybe
like we've seen now
in this time of a global pandemic
shouldn't there be strings attached for
technology sharing that we say in a case
like this
okay the public has funded this now we
also need the companies to transfer the
technology
that all sounds uh very logical but it
also sounds very time consuming
and i think time is of the essence
everybody wants the vaccine as fast as
possible but even developed nations like
the european union are struggling to get
enough vaccines
how do you convince everyone uh to share
the little we have
obviously countries like the european
union shouldn't stop vaccinations at the
moment
but we have to see that the aim of
vaccinating up to 70
of the population by the end of summer
this is a huge aim
and for us looking like doctors without
borders we look at the global picture
and we see
it cannot be that people that are not at
risk patient that are not old patients
that are not
health workers why should they enrich
nations be vaccinated before for example
health workers in poorer countries
we've seen it now we see it our teams in
malawi and eswatini and mozambique
we see mutations spreading and this is
obviously dangerous health
systems have already been struggling
before the pandemic in some countries
and now they're virtually breaking down
they're not enough intensive care units
to take care of the patients so what we
are aiming at and we
what we are calling for is for just and
global
distribution so that worldwide
especially
at risk patients and health workers can
be vaccinated first
and not as the who president de tedro
said
to have a few countries with a lot of
vaccines and
few countries with no vaccines but we
should have
all countries with few vaccines and then
time by time
scale up the immunization of the
population everywhere
because this global pandemic that's why
exactly that's why it's called a
pandemic so we have to tackle it from
that angle elizabeth masoud from doctors
without borders thank you so much for
your time
thank you